are you good at negotiating your salary
so for myself i do know that this is a
topic that is
not coming easy to me and indeed i
launched a little survey on my instagram
channel from learning
and a big majority of you confirmed that
you are saying that no you do not feel
like you are especially great
at negotiating your salary salary
negotiation
is the topic that we are going to talk
about today welcome to another coffee
break here on my channel firm learning
my name is heinrich and on my channel i
want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career to
provide you the very best
insights on this topic i partnered with
a good friend of mine for this video and
this is jens
i met jens ed mckinsey in the munich
office he's also a former mckinsey
consultant
later he transitioned to amazon and
worked there as a buyer for several
years
later then he worked at palantir
technologies and now he recently
co-founded the health tech startup so
we're going to tackle this now in the
following way
first the ends will talk a little bit
about why it's so important
to regularly negotiate your salary then
second i will talk about specifically
salary raises so what you can do if
you're already in a job
and then want to increase your salary
within your current role and then last
yes we'll share some
thoughts on value creation on how you
can jointly create value with your
employer
in a salary negotiation but the best
thing is that jens and i recreated a
full
online course on salary negotiation the
videos that you're now
seeing are just little snippets little
excerpts of the whole course
so this topic interests you like to see
more from us on it check out the link to
this new course
in the video description the course
launched this week so it really
is brand new we are very much looking
forward to what you think about it so
now without further ado
let's jump into it
the importance of salary negotiation is
really underestimated by most people
in this video we're going to show you
exactly why it is so important
to consistently negotiate your salary
first of all
it really matters for your lifetime
earnings
it makes a huge difference and research
has shown that people
who consistently negotiate their salary
over their entire lifetime
earn about 1 million dollars more
throughout their entire career
let's start with getting more i want to
show you a simple theoretical graph
that illustrates how salary negotiations
really impact your salary and how it
increases your earnings over your entire
lifetime in this case example we have
two fictional people
christian who does not negotiate his
salary so for him i assumed a one
percent increase
basically in line with inflation over
each year on the other hand there's
theodore
he negotiates his salary every three
years
and he achieves a five percent average
negotiation success
which is really in line with what you
can expect by the end of his career
theodore will earn about 140 000 each
year
well christian will be stuck at roughly
eighty thousand
so this is already a huge difference if
you add up all the years where theodore
earns
more and more money than christian
throughout that
entire career the difference is enormous
in this case example it's about 1.2
million dollar
i've oversimplified this obviously but
it really proves the point
how important it is to not be afraid of
negotiating a salary
usually your employer will respect you
more if you ask
what you are worth
so the one thing is to freshly negotiate
your salary once you get a new job
but the other thing is once you're
already in the job then also to be able
to negotiate
regular raises and this is the topic
that we are going to talk about in this
section
in this first lecture i want to talk
about what is realistic
what can you ask for a race because this
is indeed the question that at least i
get most frequently when i discuss this
topic with friends and colleagues
and here it often helps really argue
with some data so in this
lecture i want to help you by providing
a little orientation some
points of data that might help you to
guide this discussion and the first
thing to be aware of is of course the
inflation rate measured by the consumer
price index
this measures how much prices increase
on average for the consumer in every
single year
of course these values differ
significantly come to my country
so you should take this in consideration
depending on your geography that you
work in
so pulling some data for germany you can
see here that the values pretty much
fluctuate between one and two percent
per year and this is exactly the average
that you can expect for most developed
countries so one to two percent per year
annual consumer price inflation so make
sure to research this value for your
country
the index might be called a bit
differently there might be different
indices
measuring concepts like this as well for
your country so look it up in a second
similar index that might be helpful here
is the labor cost
index that shows you how much on average
the price for labor so the salaries
in the country have gone up over time
and often these values are more or less
similar in some countries the one might
be higher than the other
but here again if on average salaries go
up by two percent every year
this is where can give you a certain
indication of what you should target
though of course you should not really
be happy with just
getting a salary on the level of
inflation because if you exactly meet
the inflation number
you do not really have a salary increase
just the fact that now you can buy
next year as much things with your money
as
last year or to put it differently if
you're not even managed to get a salary
raise that needs inflation
you will lose purchasing power you
pretty much lose value all for your
money year on year
and for these reasons compensation for
inflation should pretty much be the
minimum
the minimum amount that you ask for and
that you get
when you go into these conversations so
this is the one end of the spectrum then
what is the other hand of the spectrum
and just to give you a ballpark figure
here one number that you can expect to
receive
if you work in a so-called accelerated
career environment
such as consulting or banking is roughly
an
average of a salary increase of 10 per
year so i'd argue that there are only
very very few careers very very few
roads where you can get a long-term
average salary increase of more than 10
per year so aim for these 10
in these very high pace accelerated
korean environments
but of course there's a reason that
these people get this type of money of
course in these
jobs often need to work a lot the
performance pressure on you is quite
significant
so if you are in a more general standard
nine to five
corporate job probably this is a bit
high and should be then adjusted to a
bit of a lower number
so one to two percent this is the
minimum that you should get
this is also actually what some
companies provide just by themselves as
a yearly inflation compensation to the
employees and then on top of that you
should ask for an increase that is
up to 10 based on the type of career
that you're in
and of course here the importance is
also to see this as a long-term average
so it's absolutely okay to maybe one
year not get that much of a raise
if then after two years after three
years you get an
even higher salary increase maybe if you
step up to the next higher position but
make sure that on average
these are the targets that you can
achieve
welcome to this section in which we will
talk about how to increase the overall
value
for both sides on the table this concept
is called
value creation and negotiations and it's
a very important concept
that you can also apply to salary
negotiations
so far we've really simplified the
salary negotiation
and only talked about your total
compensation
as one dollar figure but actually
there are many many different elements
that make up your total compensation
and you can make clever use of these
different elements
to create value in the negotiation it is
really a common trap or mistake people
make
in salary negotiations because they
simplify
the many different elements into one
dollar figure
and this way they go heads on with their
employer instead of thinking about
clever and nuanced ways to create value
the key insight here is the following
you should aim to negotiate for salary
components that are worth more
to you and worth less to your employer
by this way you can basically create
value
this will enable you to grow your total
compensation
by a lot your employer might be bound by
certain salary bands that are
very specific to your role and maybe you
just barely miss the qualification for a
more senior role that would also have
a different salary range of course in
this case you can try to negotiate for a
much faster review of your current role
and your promotion this gives you a much
faster runway to the next promotion
and therefore a much faster access to a
higher salary another example would be
maybe you want a different job title
because you know that if you switch
jobs it will give you a much better
salary range
this will actually cost your current
employer nothing if they can offend it
against other employees of course
but it could be worth a lot to you to
give you some ideas of
salary components that you can negotiate
for and that other people have
negotiated for
i will now show you a brief overview
besides the overall component of course
your
annual cash compensation you can
negotiate for
vacation days you can negotiate for a
sign on bonus in case you're
switching to a new employer other common
types of compensation components can be
your relocation coverage it could be a
tuition allowance
your job title as we discussed in the
previous example
it could be the early review it could be
a company car or maybe a mobility budget
or
in case of particular smaller companies
or startups
maybe you can negotiate for a visa
package or an equity option package that
gives you
a really strong incentive in the long
run to stay with the company which is
also of course interesting to your
employer
you can really extend this list to many
other elements i've shown some here
on this slide maybe if you already are a
father or a mother
you can negotiate for child care support
a parental leave
or maybe for other people a wellness or
fitness program
just look through all the components i'm
showing you here on this slide
and get creative you will find that by
opening new opportunities for your
employer to
compensate you in some sort of way be it
monetary
or in case of job titles giving you
future possibilities and future options
you can really create a lot of value for
yourself in the negotiation
as you're preparing for your next
negotiation write down the different
salary components that would be relevant
for your negotiation
now we hope that you got value out of
this video and if it is the case please
hit the like button for the youtube
algorithm and also subscribe to my
channel to stay up to date on all my
content if you want to continue your
learning journey with firm learning
i will link above here a video on
problem solving really one of the key
consulting skills
check it out to continue learning and if
you like the topic of salary negotiation
please again check out the link to the
full course
that we created on this topic in the
video description
if you want to see more from me also
follow me on my instagram my handle is
from learning or
sign up to the mailing list link in the
video description and i also want to say
thank you to all the members of firm
learning your support is very much
appreciated and check out the join
button if you are interested to become a
members way this is highly from from
learning i'm releasing new videos
every single saturday so stay tuned for
next saturday
happy easter to all of you cheers and
bye bye